the royal family's wealth is estimated
to be collectively about 442 million
dollars which
sounds pretty conservative i think when
you think of the royal family and their
wealth and their gems and their art
collection and their palaces remember
not all of them are owned by them
personally you'd be putting them into a
billionaire category
part of the problem with estimating the
royal family as well is that no one
really knows the true value of those
priceless camilettos hanging in
buckingham palace or indeed the royal
collection but i think people also
assume that things like the imperial
state crown and the crown jewels that
we've seen in recent days belong to the
queen and her family they do not they
belong to the nation it gets very tricky
when you try to break down the royal
finances and work out exactly how much
they are worth but what we do know is
that the queen passed on the duchy of
lancaster estate to king charles and
that is worth anything between
715 and up to 900 million pounds it's a
huge amount of money because quite
simply it is a massive swathe of land
and premium real estate around the
united kingdom in terms of her property
portfolio well the queen privately owns
balmoral
she privately owns sandringham but the
other royal estates namely clarence
house buckingham palace hollywood house
in scotland
they are owned by the nation i think the
queen was actually a very canny business
woman i mean let's not forget that she
changed the way the royal family were
financed she voluntarily paid income tax
on her earnings thus really diverting
any criticism over the wealth of the
royal family
and she got expenditure down to the
royal family essentially costing each
member of the british public less than
two pounds so less than
say four dollars i think most people
would argue that's pretty good value for
money when you think about the royal
family it's hard to put a price on them
i mean we actually can because we know
what they cost us the british taxpayer
in terms of security and arrangements
and expenditure through the year that's
less than two pounds so say around four
dollars
what it's harder to put a price on is
what they generate for the country you
know monarchy plc as a business well
that's priceless another area where we
saw the queen really show her business
acumen was in opening up the palaces it
was clever for two reasons one it made
the royal family more accessible more
relatable and in turn more popular
but secondly it earned a huge amount of
money i would imagine that with the king
it'll be again his flunkies who pull out
the credit cards or the cash i remember
one occasion being in malta with charles
and camilla on an official engagement
and i found myself in a bizarre
situation shopping in a glass shop with
camilla and she was picking out all
these beautiful glass christmas trees as
presents to take home so i copied her
and when he got to the till realized
that i was the one with the money and of
course she stood there while a flunky
moved in and
a deal was struck the money or however
it was handed over but it was very
apparent to me there and then the royals
do not carry cash when you look at the
main financial picture for the royal
family the assets are land that the
assets are regent street and the most
expensive streets in the capital and
that land is divided between the duchy
of lancaster which is the sovereign's
estate and the duchy of cornwall which
has now been inherited by prince william
what does it mean well essentially that
the royal family is very very wealthy
there has been a lot of scrutiny over
the royal family as well particularly
with regards to some of the crown jewels
and the jewelry that the queen has been
gifted or inherited over the years
and along with calls for reparations for
slavery dating back to colonialism there
have also been calls from south africa
from india to return some of the
diamonds the rubies and the stones
gifted to the queen some of which are
set in priceless pieces of of royal
paraphernalia
for these to be returned to their home
countries i think when it when it comes
to dismantling crowns and taking apart
priceless pieces of of the royal
collection um i think it's
it's particularly troublesome times
ahead
[Music]